y ya comienzan a escucharse las primeras
reacciones en el marco de la cop 15 la
Cumbre de las Naciones Unidas para la
biodiversidad que se celebra desde este
7 de diciembre en el Palacio de
congresos de Montreal en el día de hoy
este viernes distintos actores de la
sociedad civil se pronunciaron sobre lo
que ellos consideran un lento avance de
las negociaciones hacia ese marco global
para la biodiversidad que se espera que
se pueda pactar de aquí al 19 de
diciembre fecha en que termina esta
importante Cumbre
estos sectores están sumamente
preocupados porque la semana que viene
debería arribar a Montreal el segmento
de alto nivel compuesto por ministros y
altos funcionarios para pisar el
acelerador final a las negociaciones en
el día de hoy también el director
general del fondo mundial para la
naturaleza dijo que hay nueve líderes de
países Incluyendo a la Unión Europea que
están comprometidos con la agenda de la
biodiversidad Pero dijo que era
necesario un marco global para que estos
compromisos se llevar a la práctica dijo
también que hoy en día todas las
expectativas están puestas sobre
Montreal debido a que los resultados de
la cop 27 que se celebró recientemente
en Egipto no fueron los esperados invito
también a los gobiernos a dejar de lado
ese mínimo viable que están dispuestos a
negociar y hacer lo que es mejor para el
planeta